hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet in this little clip i'm
speaking to my friend karma medic on the
podcast and we're talking about the idea
of what it means to have meaningful work
and we're referencing this absolutely
fantastic book by paul millard called
the pathless path imagining a new story
for work and life so if you're
interested in finding more meaningful
work or at least how to productivity
youtuber bros think about it then i hope
you'll enjoy this clip part of it is
also like this deeply ingrained sort of
thinking that is in my head and i guess
of people in my generation as well that
like in order to have success in order
to have happiness in order to whatever
you need to be working hard you need to
be in a high stress environment you need
to be pushing yourself um which is
probably not true at all but it's kind
of like an intrinsic feeling of like you
want to be doing something that's
intense not necessarily stressful but
like get your blood going
yeah there's definitely like i've been
doing a bunch of reading into this as
well this
culture of or this narrative that
hard work is itself a virtue
and i think this is a very
it's a very like pervasive um
thing and it it's it's not necessarily
always bad all the time
but
i've begun to think
how
where this comes from the whole like
1500's the protestant work ethic the
idea that working hard is itself a
virtue that brings you closer to god and
it's not just about the fruits of your
labor it's also about how hard you work
for it
and
there's this you know this is a really
good book um by paul millard oh
i've got a lot of copies there gives you
a copy of this it's sick the pathless
path imagining a new story for work and
life where he used to be like a
management consultant new york et cetera
et cetera
then
ended up leaving his job after a few
years and
kind of massively cutting down his
salary just doing a little freelance
stuff here and there and just doing the
whole slow living exploring the world
and he writes a lot about this
kind of
history of workism and where the idea
that hard work is a virtue comes from
and i think it's all it's all very
interesting and it's something that i'm
grappling with
as well
um
because yeah
it i think it's definitely something
that's ingrained in us to some extent
maybe not so much in people who are like
five years or so younger than us but
certainly for me and and a lot of my
friend group and how my parents raised
me it's like you need to work hard why
do you need to work hard well just
because like you know that's what you do
like you go to uni then you work hard
and you support your family and
um and you know that's how you thrive
um and so a lot of like sitting down and
studying or going to work is just this
is what i'm supposed to do it's this
natural drive that's kind of within us i
think if we all took a step back and
think about it a little bit more we'd
realize this probably isn't the case and
we shouldn't think of it like that um
but i just feel like something deeply
ingrained inside um
you mentioned that maybe not for people
five years younger than us what
like you probably speak to students who
are like in their
late teens early 20s what
what's their vibe
a huge generalization incoming but
people of my parents age and maybe our
grandparents age their whole sort of
life um goals was
go to university get a good job and then
you've made it in life you are
successful you have your career you have
your family you're good that's what
you're supposed to do right whereas i
feel like for a lot of people our age
now and younger that isn't where the
primary source of happiness is coming
from i think people want to have a wider
impact they want to
focus a lot more on their social life on
their personal life and then their job
is just kind of something that they do
to sustain themselves whereas in the
past the job was the one thing that you
did kind of mental health wasn't
important social life wasn't important
it was all about sacrifice sacrifice
sacrifice big generalization
and so yeah i think people who are a bit
younger than us
place a bigger importance on mental
health and having fun and
balance in their life than maybe someone
who has come like myself who's come from
a migrant family and thinks you know i
need to get my education need to get a
good job i need to have a family blah
blah blah
yeah one of the things that paul miller
talks about in the book um and he's got
a tweet thread about this is the
accidental threads oh that's so good
there's like a good condensation of like
what you know sometimes in the book um
the the accidental meaning hypothesis
but the idea there is that for our
parents generation um
going to university getting that good
job staying with ibm for 50 years
working your way up getting the company
car and the health insurance
was in fact a recipe for a meaningful
life back when we lived out in where
when we lived in the suburbs the people
were very involved in the community uh
controversial point but like the
traditional family unit was a bit more
of a thing you would go to church on
sundays you would have like you would
you would know who your neighbors are
and
if you followed that path just by virtue
of the fact that that was your life
setup life felt pretty meaningful like
you have community you have family you
have a social life by default um
nowadays where we live in a bigger
sporting apartment buildings we have no
idea who the hell and neighbors are
fewer fewer people are for example
living with their families and living in
their local communities and getting
involved with the local communities and
it's all about like how do i get ahead
in my career et cetera et cetera um
now the model of oh i'll just work at
the same job for 40 years no longer
leads to accidental
meaningful fulfilling life and now he's
and therefore we have to think harder
about what are the elements of a
meaningful and fulfilling life that we
just don't have by default and
incorporating them actively into our
life rather than passively by default
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day